hey everybody welcome to stream Coco
that really hurt that Marie I broke a
rib that like oh the whole couch moved
oh that's a bad idea that's a bad idea
welcome everybody I'm wearing a ramen
beef situation here as you can see I am
already getting ready for Halloween this
is a costume I will not be doing for
Halloween but thinking about it I'm you
know beef right we love beef Beth
Morosky is on the couch and in the chat
she'll bring down the banhammer there's
her hand right there so act nice and we
got Jason O'Malley creeper in the corner
we're gonna have a special guest
possibly two special guests this this
little session we're playing Friday the
13th god I love this game
greatest game ever if you haven't played
it you've wasted your life up to this
point it's super fun and fantastic
hello rising 7 keV Larsen good to see
you Madeline Sims of course how are you
doing happy October so you want to play
with us just add me on PlayStation my
name my gamertag my last name is Blair
ble why AE e RT it's like god misspelled
my name it's all vowels it's a mess and
add that on ps4 and get Friday 13th and
we'll play it's gonna be fantastic burn
the beef exactly thank you about the
dope hoodie everybody the Internet has
amazing things oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah soup soup soup soup soup soup
okay enough of this I know you all want
to see me get murdered so let's just get
into it shall we
[Music]
there's somebody that's true but I got
beef because I think beef is funnier
you're gonna go chicken ramen noodle
soup situation you want to go you want
to go beef you want to go beef I can do
me a flavor and make that can you make
that the actual exploit window kind of
tiny small sofa troll give me Conan I
don't know maybe Carl be here who knows
oh you know the other thing I have to do
is mute everybody oh that's right yeah
we can't now he's I don't even know
honestly if he's here oh there we go
fantastic Oh is he so that's why we
can't I'm muting everybody sorry guys I
just I don't want to hear you I I have
no desire to hear you but I am ready to
roll I'm ready - let's do it this is a
new format for Kody yes Bravo
Fredrickson hello my name is Conan
O'Brien this is the new format you like
my knee thank you why did I buy jeans
with holes in them I don't know there
I'm pretty religious guy cuz they're
holey jeans thank you
thank you can I get a high-five Oh oh my
god shut down shut down [ __ ] thank
you smiling dinosaurs it's your birthday
today Nicholas ray that's awesome well
for your birthday you're gonna watch me
get my ass killed to death I wish I was
sponsored by Robin tell the ramen people
tell Top Ramen this is happening and
that they should pay us money because
that would be great I need all the money
I can get because look my luck these
jeans are falling apart wanna watch porn
no actually I would rather play this
game than watch porn right now I'm gonna
be honest cuz I'm a nerd and this game
is super fun and way more exciting porn
you kind of know where it's going
you know Oh what I gotta meet some
sounds like somebody's talking here
that's the one thing about porn guys I
think sometimes it should not work out
there should be stakes you know it would
make it more exciting like you know like
oh the pizza delivery guys here blue
buddy blob-like who cares like you know
where it's gonna end up but what if the
pizza delivery
it doesn't work out you know then it's
like ooh I actually want to see this
Ellie see how it ends so I'm just saying
can you please bring bring back clue
this game I'm trying Mega Mike I'm
really trying the last few weeks have
been as I'm sure you guys had know very
busy and crazy and we said goodbye to
our band on Thursday which is a big deal
you know they've worked for worked with
us and with Conan for 25 years I watched
them play at Conan's wedding and we went
on tour with them and so that was kind
of a big deal to say goodbye to those
guys so and we're going on tour we're
getting ready for our tour starts
November 2nd in Washington DC
go to team cocom / tour I think there's
still some tickets available in select
cities like Milwaukee so you walk ian's
or millions or Milwaukeeans what are you
guys called Milwaukee Milwaukee we knows
Milwaukee Milwaukee acts whatever uh go
get tickets for the show
yo it's up Anton one guy not muted I
know Park for life I think I did mute
his ass though oh no wait I gotta meet
his ass now can i mute his ass mute
players boom I don't know what I'm doing
oh boy we got soy cerebro is not muted
and I can't mute him till the game
starts No
mute him I don't want to leave match oh
god here we go
I would like to mute players though soy
cerebrum this is my favorite part
alright let's go let's go on the yo yo
yo yo yo a mouse I'm at least like
texting over there I don't know what
he's doing not paying attention all
right here we go
Oh first of all wait Senate I don't want
okay okay I get it all right I've kind
of forgotten how to play this game now
for those of you who have never seen me
play this game I'm terrible at it so I'm
gonna need your help on knowing what to
do
so anybody want to help me please for my
birthday can you have cones happy
birthday to me okay man if he comes in
for sure who knows all right let's just
run around here kind of remember how to
do Stu okay look behind you great up
something over here
oh yeah got the shotgun baby oh hell
yeah
okay cool all right I'm feeling better
already
flashlight flashlight flashlight
that's Crouch flashlight there we go
no I love this kid we're playing this
game cuz it's October yeah I play full
price for this and you know what we had
one of the creator's come on one time
and play with us
and he killed everyone in like four
seconds to remember that it was awesome
all right I hate this game by the way I
remember this game being very scary oh
there's some other people in the house
hey guys
alright let's go I think I do better
when I follow other people in this game
I have played spider-man we played it I
think last time two times ago on stream
Coco I also did a fun dinner in a video
game
if you guys want to see me cook terrible
things go to dinner new video game calm
I did slider man
so it was spider-man spider-man and I
made sliders ooh get that trap there we
go so I made carnage asada sliders Thank
You doc ock spicy calamari sliders and
I'm just gonna follow this guy uh-oh and
Peter porker pulled pork sliders and
guess what I drank what would be the
drink that you would think during a
spider-man pun the themed thing J jonah
Jameson whiskey of course O'Malley's
favorite yeah my PSN is blurt it's just
my last name you want me to move back
there we go I'm your puppet O'Malley you
just tell me what to do oh god don't
pull that out how I run god don't call
it what are you doing oh oh he's here
where is he where is he I see you dick
oh I shot him I shot him guys
yes that was awesome
oh my god I've never shot him before
that was so cool and now I'm running
away oh [ __ ] he's after us oh Jesus
is he still after me oh Jesus Christ
he's after me
yeah kill the other person don't trip oh
he's definitely killing that other
person how do I crouch how do I crouch
Oh God can I just stay here and he won't
find me maybe I'll just stay here hidden
in plain sight hidden in plain sight
hidden in plain sight oh Christ
hidden in plain sight
I'm not hitting the plate sight no I'm
not hidden in plain sight oh Jesus
Christ oh no run towards other belgique
no no no please go I hate this game what
am i play in this game I hate this game
so much this game is the worst game I
know SOI I know
[ __ ] oh my god this dude is after my ass
Jesus Christ
can I head into the bed hon out of the
bed
oh my god I'm so [ __ ]
can I get in here maybe I can get in
here am i dying why is it going on oh
yeah all right is he in there
everybody's horribly afraid this is why
what place there's no one else MIT oh
there he is there he is
see I think he's not gonna remember that
oh there we go
now that person is smart to leave I
should oh yes yes oh thank Jesus oh
thank god
don't try to get in here you get away
from me this is my cabinet just lie down
to the bed and play dead that doesn't
work
don't run back in here you a-holes
everyone is just clustered in here oh my
god we're just gonna watch these people
get brutally murdered by the way they're
also in this game they're all different
Jason oh my god he's chasing this person
around the thing Oh God
maybe I should just run oh god I just
run out oh my god oh my god oh no this
is horrible it's behind the valley there
we go see oh no no no no don't is that a
trap or something you said maybe he
won't remember I'm in here ah no I don't
want him to get hit with a trap oh it
worked it worked he didn't know he was
in there oh my strategy is selling
everyone else out and hiding worked
perfectly he could sense I'm in here now
if I hold my breath right
I shouldn't have ran I was killing the
others but I didn't and that was stupid
all right what do we think what do we
think of plan is what do you think a
plan is I think he's gone right what oh
no why is the music still playing Oh God
Jason is tech-savvy in 2018 uh so my egg
a chicken I don't think so you please
upcoming coming in wish you happy
birthday Nikolas right I can't control
Conan you should know that by now
all right let's look at oh no map found
cool oh my god somebody used the
motorboat to escape
wait how are we doing where do I where
can I find the players killed officiate
aah Elin area escaped oh I'm the only
person alive cool uh great
so it's just me and Jason all right so
what do I have to do oh my god I'm so
screwed okay repair the phone box I let
my friends die find a weapon I had a
weapon all right sorry okay here we go
wait can't I just wait him out I know
nobody wants to watch that but I would
like to live I can write search drawers
inside buildings this bearded Patriot
all right okay I'm going out guys
I'm really hurt ah [ __ ] shut up yeah
it's a person you dumbass oh my god
what's happening why am I like what if I
get in the light well here's a floating
pot I'm probably scared of this floating
pot is this light gonna help me Oh
perfect
oh my god this would a mess okay well
let's go towards the car I guess he's
probably waiting at the car though right
is there another boat the pot is haunted
call the cops then run to the flashing
lights all right Ricky Bob's her play on
ps4 oh he's definitely come after me
where can I run to all right the key all
right I need to go to the right when I
leave here the thing is he knows exactly
where I I'm so screwed man oh here he is
okay well why even try to break free Oh
God
Oh No Oh oh man all those Oh God Jesus
Lord all right well now we're gonna play
with you guys that was horrifying
oh yes Jason good boy good boy this
guy's so dumb it hurts to watch him play
that's true bearded patriot i'm
toughening you up oh boy
i'm not quite sure what's happening here
cool all right well good job
Aylin I think that's my mood oh yeah
sure yeah we've got a new mic situation
that's extremely specific so I need to
stay in a in a very six-inch box to make
sure you can hear me tis but a flesh
wound
all right let's leave dis band by party
rub some bacon in it I've had worse to
Sealab Thank You chicken 237 okay so now
let's create a party shall we create a
potty okay invites a party now we're
gonna invite some folks
again okay let's see here let's see
let's see let's see so we're playing up
here we go we got a Celeste in the house
how many people are in a party six it's
the first six people who I see are
playing this if there are six people
playing we'll see
yes we are going on tour everybody very
exciting on November 2nd we're hitting
what 18 cities Beth 18 cities like
Detroit Austin Nashville Houston Port
Chester Port Chester
I can't wait I've never been to Port
Chester I don't even know what to expect
I'm very excited and of course in New
York City we love a good New York we'll
be doing some shows here in LA
we'll be doing some shows in
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh Boston which will be
fun and yeah we're looking forward to it
it's gonna be great so and of course if
you can't join us on tour you will be
able to join us via this thing called
the internet we'll be covering it of
course
like we do with the travel shows so make
sure you subscribe to our Instagram at
team cocoa at Conan O'Brien on Twitter
of course you know our YouTube our
Facebook team cocoa all those things and
yeah we're gonna be doing a lot of
really fun stuff I want what I want from
you guys is great food recommendations I
plan on eating my way across this
country and some of Canada I'm meaning
Vancouver and I plan on eating an
amazing crazy meal at each stop I got to
find also if you guys I would love so
okay that's it we get that's everyone
else is not online all right we only got
two folks well I'm inviting them to the
thing um last time we went on tour I did
a fun thing in each city I stole a salt
shaker so I have like however many salt
shakers from like three months on tour
this one I want to try to figure out
something to do in every city so far it
could be like eating hot wings in every
city or like you know I want to try to
do something for every single thing you
like my jacket thank you it's very beefy
unfortunately doesn't smell like beef
ramen but I think Beth and O'Malley are
happy that it
doesn't that cover is all Chinese food
interesting all right who that's why I
wonder why Vancouver holding down the
fort in LA that's right that's will be
here hold another fort in LA and
O'Malley's trying to adjust the mic yeah
you should just why don't you just add a
mic to the camera or why isn't there a
mic on the camera anyway great question
calling the cops now sis our it sounds
good when you when we do a when we do a
YouTube Q&A once every year but not for
the thing we do every week so that's
Robin in every city that's not a bad
idea although house like Nashville's
ramen is they're good now is there good
ramen in Port Chester oh there we go
was it like a tex-mex Robin yeah how am
i doing man good streamer 478 all right
nobody's getting in this thing so guys I
don't know what to tell you I mean I'll
go look for very quickly for friend
requests if you guys want to play but
you got to get on this if you want to
play who knows who'll show up this time
and who you'll be able to play Friday
the 13th with I was thinking I love
Halloween
what's everybody going as for Halloween
and don't say sexy anything because
that's dumb but I was thinking of going
as the sexy Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
cannot load great this is good
weird goat we're doing great so far so
we do some accepting of friends here
nope nope go back we go accepting some
friend requests hopefully we can get a
cool party here it's so much more fun to
play with you guys if you guys are
watching at home of course or watching
in class add me on PSN my last name is
Blaire and then you'll be able to play
with us here great great great greetings
from Turkey hey do you guys celebrate
Halloween at Turkey I always love
hearing we're in different countries
like the traditions
different holidays makes me happy I'm
gonna do one more invite to party we're
gonna play again because nobody wants to
see me just add people on PlayStation is
boring okay we only got two people in
the party though yep already added I
already added yeah I got I got that so
this game was free that's interesting oh
I see
worth it though by the way one of my
favourite games and it's so scary it's
so scary obviously cuz I'm weeping like
little girl alright it's all we got
alright well that's what we got guys I
know what to say
Halloween is very small in Europe
interesting play dead by daylight I
don't like dead by daylight LeBrons that
by daylight isn't this fun to me because
the boards are smaller and even though
you can like that there's different
killers and stuff it's just not as it's
more of like a this is more of a
creeping around game which I like and
and dead by dough my god what's
happening oh wow I realize people are in
it oh it's got a mute everybody I don't
want to hear from anybody
I don't want to hear from a single
person I don't like talking to people
sorry y'all sorry bear ski gotta meet
your ass it just happens
I'm ready to go though let's do it
everybody's muted and we're ready to
play let's play let's play let's play
there's ski I don't want to see you just
creeping around bear ski just likes to
go off in the woods and just this is my
bear ski impression creepy creepy so
small we want to see Sona
so do I do SH at you but Sona it's 1:26
and she's probably getting lunch or
second lunch I know how many lunches
creeping around is something I'm good at
that's true creeping about that's what I
love to do let's get this thing started
MacNeil yo let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go here we go
get rekt bear ski my worrying depends no
but you know what I have thought about
wearing depends cuz I'm really lazy and
it would be fun to just not have to go
to the bathroom all the time you can
just sit where everyone
oh yeah Halloween also got into our
culture in Turkey people celebrated here
hope you guys send me travel at records
Kona I'd love to go to Turkey sitting
here ready to play talk bomb in the
house talk bomb what's your what's your
thing oh here we go alright guys let's
do this I kind of hope I'm not Jason cuz
I'm actually more nervous when I'm Jason
oh this is my favorite part
Higgins Haven Oh AJ oh he's gonna put
some of these face in the fire face in
the fire Oh
Oh Oh I take that back east
oh my god it's spear Jason oh I'm Jason
all right here we go
oh you guys are so you guys are so safe
because I don't know so that's his mom
so basically yeah the idea is Jason was
a camper all these counselors were
having sex and like not paying attention
to the campers and Jason died he drowned
in the which is why it's faces all
messed up because he was like whatever
underwater for millions of years not
millions of years but so and so now he
takes revenge on the counselors in the
first movie his mom is the killer she's
the killer
there's no Jason Jason doesn't appear in
the first one and so he does things for
his mom so it's kind of close to a sense
that's a good question I don't I don't
know can i morph
oh yes oh I hear noise hey there
everybody
haha oh this Jason's real strong and
slow hi-yah oh wow we swear rise Jason
ah the best no oh uh I think Tommy
Jarvis can hurt him enough for he's
almost killed ten tenten tenten tenten
tenten maybe I could throw stuff to you
with this Jason
see this this guy can only walk fast I'm
gonna go into the barn oh man I'm so bad
at being Jason you guys get ready
everybody watching get ready to be very
frustrated oh dude you're right there
I'm just coming after you
and then that didn't shift what is
shifty ah went too far
oh I got my mind set on you I got my
mind set on you Jason becomes a comedy
lead in places that's true coming this
fall the TBS it's Jason in the woods oh
I don't think breaking through this is a
great idea this seems like stupid but
I'm gonna do it anyway maybe they
haven't left
oh they're dumb they didn't leave that
it that that it the dirt that it damn it
they did leave Wow all I'm doing is just
hitting walls god dammit uh ah wait
ah somebody in here
oh hey you didn't leave ah push it off
shake it off Jason where are you
they're not under here are they no damn
it
uh this sucks I'm terrible at this game
alright you didn't break through you
wouldn't be a horse savvy that's true
where do they go
no he opens the door like a gentleman hi
hi mister
I see somebody's got a flare gun
that's right run run Jason's my main man
Kane Hodder did mocap for this i ah god
they're really get how many flare guns
are in this camp are you guys in here
are they outside I think they're outside
they're smart they left already
hi get him get it no oh he's Jason I
just got hit with a stick twice Jesus
Christ
Oh get his ass don't let him escape
where'd he go
guys any tit if I hold down r2 then
you'll hit doors fashion tapping it okay
hmm where should I go Beth the world is
my oyster oh well well let's use our
sense wait what's the sense one alright
sense Oh somebody's in here
let's get them other a couple people in
there oh well let's fix that problem
right now
oh it's just music it's not gonna be
anything Nicholas ray you got to stop
with the birthday thing dude I mean
there's a trap Jesus even the oyster
could escape this Jason that's true
hey okay dude I get it
hmmm it's gonna break through every door
oh hey what's up stuff those can get to
see it pick them up when you find them
how do I pick them up I'm like friendly
Jason I just want to say hi
how do I stop ah hey hey come back how
do I pick them up just would you please
hit her or something gee god oh my god
this is like the worst I'm the worst at
this
don't try to hide how do I chase them
faster why don't you walk slower dude
get er these buttons not working or
something damn it here we go
all I'd want to do is just kill one
person is that possible in this game
maybe I should hide in the house and let
them come to me everything about that
why not try going like near a car or
something do you think that's a good
idea
push our three - no our three isn't it
itself three I think
hi hey everybody I see you guys all
working on this car get him
I'll do it
all I could just kill one person you
know you could probably stand still and
he'd be fine honestly
bro
this is just the rest of this stream me
chasing this guy around the car
hey God how do I pick somebody up this
is crazy set a trap on the engine
alright fine
how do I set a trap
l1 down okay good one and then down well
I got a trap there oh my god sorry guys
I know this is incredibly frustrating
for everyone involved well that was a
bad idea hiding there look at that
dammit or Diddy
now usually shifts to like a different
cinematic I mean might as well just
destroy this stuff it's fun to stab take
the car l2 l2 to pick and grab got it
oh he's still in there somehow where's
the up back yeah
a mile I guess you guys think I'm even a
scary Jason you think these people are
even scared of me probably not right hey
get back here
now that I got the grab thing down this
dudes dead walk faster god damn it
just walk faster this is the most
frustrating stream I've ever done in my
life I can't catch a single get him get
him
yes Oh finally alright just kill him or
something what do i do what do I do now
what do oh my god come on come on
Jesus oh I had him him literally in my
grasp
that's right try to open the door
there's a trap there try to open the
door try to open the door
just run around the car you'll get in my
trap isn't there a goddamn trap here or
something
you could throw knives in them with l1 I
think I'm a lot of knives though man
whoever this guy is in the chat it has
to be laughing his ass up everybody's
laughing I'm so bad at this
oh I can't walk under that no now he's
gonna lock the goddamn door
I gotta hit square Oh square to kill him
see I don't Hey
okay
oh no oh everybody's just nobody's
afraid of me now we're just coming at me
grab somebody grab somebody grab them
would you gun just grab a single person
oh cool Tommy Jarvis is here great oh
damn it no it's afraid of my Jason look
at this they're all just hitting me with
abandon oh my god this is hilarious the
guy's literally prancing Polly for me
grab him grab a person can they kill me
hey get away from me okay now what do I
do
oh it got stabbed in the neck oh my God
look at my face it's all messed up can I
kill this dude or what or X oh oh there
we go finally I killed one dude oh [ __ ]
killed one person great yeah there we go
you're welcome ah all right well at
least I can kill somebody now is anybody
else anywhere no one else in the house
somebody over here somewhere where the
hell go to this is me at Saturday night
just my friends leaving me
oh they have Tommy if they get Jason's
mom's sweater they can kill me oh you
can't be killed
well I'm sure it's gonna happen alright
here we go here we go alright let's get
in there let's get in there let's do
some damage
alright ah gotcha now what do I do X I
killed another person two down oh right
in the head you know that's in medieval
times that's the way they cured
headaches I think or maybe it was
leeches
alright MA back it off okay I'm not
doing this for you mom I'm doing it for
me alright they're getting ready to do
something grab him grab him grab him
grab Tommy got it
yeah oh damn it the penknife in the neck
wow I really I this is what I'm worried
about having a Jeep and not like putting
suntan lotion on that's what I yeah
when you get it yeah exactly or
something where like a visor or
something you know I mean it's really
bad are they in here somewhere
no I did here's
did here somebody oh wow they're both on
the other side of the house
I mean I'm gonna tell you guys who are
playing with me in the chat here you
have a good chance to kill me
if you've ever if you've ever wanted to
kill Jason you easily can do it
all right there we go
ooh I like see the music is fun when
you're Jason du tututut don't you this
guy
Jesus such a [ __ ] worst dude I felt
like you were tough man what is the
thing the stalking thing what is that
does that like allow me to sneak up on
them or something
somebody get him or kill him or
something
yeah oh alright three down let's go
let's go we could do this I'm trying bro
ah yes there we go
drown them or something cool oh damn it
what do you do like okay stop it Mach
get off my back
Jesus even like in death my mom won't
leave me alone
yeah Sam get pretty oh that killed him
just throwing him through a thing was
lame oh okay mom I got it thank you
oh no did somebody survived ah four out
of eight oh yeah the stalking part of
silence is your presence it doesn't play
your music so they can ah I got it got
it well they didn't kill me so that was
good yeah oh you can't drive oh how the
turn turntables have tabled mommy's
proud thanks MA
the Savini held Jason is an awesome
design two baths exclusivity Kickstarter
backers I think I saw that one alright I
think we have time for one more game I
think we I think I saw that one when the
guy played it was like a trident and
like it was a flaming Jason I should
voice act for this game jeez mom clean
your room Jason I know rising seven the
others joining us for playing Friday the
13th it's an amazing game I'm dressed as
ramen because you know it's Halloween's
coming up so we're doing costumes this
is my rock this is my ramen cosplay it's
beef and I naturally smell like beef so
that's why when I wear this it's not
weird or when I wear anything else it's
super weird
um who's ready who's ready all right
isn't too bad there we go clean your
room Jason go to team koco.com slash
tour for all of our tour dates there's
still some tickets available we're their
tickets available Beth
we don't know most of these except New
York there's still a few tickets
available for Conan and Friends Team
Coco presents Conan and Friends a night
of stand-up and investment tips and
spoiler alert there will probably be
very few if any investment is so don't
come asking with questions about
investment we don't really know anything
but we do know a lot about stand-up a
lot about comedy and Conan and a bunch
of our friends will be there we're
talking James Veatch we're talking Ron
Funches we're talking Moses storm we're
talking Laurie Kilmartin
we're talking a whole host of amazing
people other people I can't think of
marina Franklin's gonna be there Taylor
Tomlinson the hilarious Taylor Tomlinson
and of course our friend Flula Borg
we'll be there the entire tour so we're
really excited about that but come on
out and see all of us and of course
Conan will be there as well
I'm about doing something it's gonna be
fantastic no plans to tour Europe yet
but we will be going to Vancouver as
they say that the Europe of North
America so we'll be there Bob Belcher
says I love Beth and beef best dream
yeah oh come on it's great when you
high-five me off camera I love that hand
coming in all right this give me the
last game guys so let's get her done
hi dude we're the Japan episodes Japan
do we have an airdate for that it's
airing very soon Pinehurst in 89
Wow oh I see an ax this is why you
shouldn't leave your axe in the rain
because Jason will take it and start
killing people
with the cue card guys did stand up
they're really funny uh they are really
funny Eric Willett Kowski great cue card
guy hilarious stand-up as well
any performers are on la he'll be doing
dinner in a video game with me if
they're going to do shadow of the shroom
Raider instead of Tomb Raider which will
be fun this weekend Saturday night seven
o'clock tune in to Adina video game calm
and I'll be playing either to shadow of
the shroom Raider or torte nights
fortnight where you make a torte and I
welcome all videogame pawns that was a
fan suggestion by the way tour tonight
all right
all right guys last game I think I could
really could escape here the end of the
game I'm sorry it's too late it's
crawling here man
all right what are we doing here I would
like to make this go oh oh this is bad
this is bad it's very bad
where's he at where's he at there is
let's go let's go sorry I'm out of here
bye
Oh is he chasing somebody else
that's just gtfo man let's get out of
here but I guess the cars right there
right I can't go across this way
the cars here so he's probably gonna be
hanging out around here it also means
the gas and stuff is around here make
sure to occasionally check the bigmack
to see people have dropped the key items
well I don't have the big map I think
he's definitely hanging out near the car
bear ski am I'm running into I might be
running into a mess is he in here if so
I just did something really dumb
I'll take that bat is he in here
this is bad oh Jesus he's right there oh
Jesus Christ
hit him oh Jesus no oh yeah there we go
there we go I got him I got him let's
get the [ __ ] out of here man this is
really bad he's gonna be after me in a
second just put some distance you know
let's put some distance between us oh
I'm so dead I thought it's putting
distance between us putting distance
between us let's go let's go let's go oh
god no no no no no no no no no no no oh
come on Ron you sumbitch oh that doors
locked this is very bad this is very bad
this is very bad this is not going well
this is not going well can I just get in
the water can I swim can I swim away
it's one-way swim away dude what
happened Oh No Oh God
I didn't know he could do that was
horrifying I have been killed so many
ways in this game and never that way
mama didn't raise me in no barn I don't
know what that Oh in terms of closing
the door oh no oh God Gobert ski go yeah
oh this guy oh my god this guy is really
good at morphing go bear ski go run run
oh then Virg you Fergus boys I don't
know if that's oh wow look at that Juke
that was awesome whoa that was super
smart I'm picking up some tips you see
that Juke he walked this way and she
just went around oh now she's following
him whoa dude I wait now she's running
in front of him
now that's dumb why are you running in
front of him that's really stupid oh
you're running towards the people that's
smart
oh my god good lord Oh Oh God
you could just swim them up it's one
more game I'm sorry we can't play
another game I just need to watch to see
how this works out no no I got four more
minutes
all right I love this sweater this cool
sweater 3 1989 oh we got a Tommy Jarvis
dope oh this isn't good
oh this isn't good this isn't good Ron
dude hey you know what's interesting as
I'm learning like maybe following him
might be a good boo what's going on here
Bob Belcher well Jason is insane and
trying to kill everybody why did I ask
Jordan is MTBI type I don't know what
that means
did I ever ask him that I never asked
him that so maybe you what you want to
ask his why didn't you I don't know
we'll get in the canoe I'll let you know
what I'm learning is like oh snap oh
snap
get him Tommy get him oh he got him nice
hey Bob playing any with you two please
hide all right guys let's do this let's
get that car together let's get that car
together everyone's is running Benny I
didn't ask him that I think scream of
gasps find Barsky where is bear ski at
there's bear ski Oh bear skis Tommy
I've learned yeah well I've learned not
to swim away from Jason where is he now
where's he at I hear the music but I
don't see him anywhere oh come on guys
please I need this to happen
at least he's not playing in the nude
that's true well I do appreciate the
fact Jason is always clothed because he
doesn't have to be he probably doesn't
feel cold or heat you know guys you can
do this I believe in you fix the phone
Oh
Tommy's getting a new weapon we got them
Vargas boys over here sweater cool
sweaters just hanging out by herself
oh Jesus she's covered in blood oh my
god I do we learn not to swim what are
you doing now this is real bad
now they're all swimming guys didn't you
see what happened with me a crazy naked
guy would be scarier I guess I don't
know probably that's why the isn't that
why the Scott's a Scotsman like fought
with nothing under their kilts is that
is that the thing like like Braveheart
or whatever like they would lift their
kilts up and be like yeah and then
they'd go fight with people
intimidation man are you bringing
podcasts soon hopefully no hopefully oh
it's cool sweater
oh cool sweater is gonna get killed this
is really bad cool sweater Juke him run
out the door this is a nice house Joo
Kim Joo Kim cool sweater what is Jason
doing he's just wandering around
Oh someone's following Jason oh my god
get him
we're like Jason's not trying to kill
anybody I don't think so I guess I'm
good I'm learning that a good technique
is to follow is just a frame oh Jesus
oh it's just to follow Jason that seems
to work really well
Oh go bear ski go oh this is
there's some weird what's up with the
fireworks look at that Oh Tommy Wow
Tommy's arm got cut off that sucks oh my
god
oh no that's him
can you beat Jason to death with Tommy's
arm
music is that different point for
everybody is just Jason's near everybody
oh he's out back
oh no what are they trying to do just
beat him up you know what reach a fan
treat your friend I haven't seen Jason
is just like hanging out look at this
wait are you guys just like hanging out
with Jason he's not doing anything they
all just decided not to kill each other
oh that's nice Jason's a helper all
right well I guess we're gonna end there
kids
Jason's not trying to kill anybody
anymore so uh that's it
although how many people are left okay
[Laughter]
what Jason is not this is weird
Jason's not doing anything unless just
crazy lag it's Jason just helping them I
don't know what's happening
all right kids well it's 2 o'clock we
got to go this is super fun thank you
for joining us we're never go to t go go
calm slashed or two there's still a few
tickets in select cities available for
our team Coco presents opponent of
friends
a night of stand-up and investment tips
you'll see people like Conan O'Brien
James Beach Flula Borg Moses Storm Ron
Funches
Lori Kyle Martin marina Franklin and
much much more
a lot of good tour merch is gonna be on
sale I'm very excited about that and of
course you can watch all the action on
all of our social channels we're missing
people getting killed on Instagram
YouTube Facebook um what else we might
think yep
Twitter of course we love a good flim
flam and JibJab
all these amazing cool new social
platforms follow us on all that stuff
and we will see you guys next week for
another Halloween stream go go booze
[Music]